oh what would you have done b thursday
night show
yeah when first night yeah hanging out
hanging out
jay stick ass comes around the room run
run he's gathering everybody up like
captain america
there's a guy with a knife or gun out
there he's trying to get in here and
we're like what the [ __ ] he's got a
knife
and we're like what so then big david
lucas he opens the door he's like where
he's at and jay said shut the [ __ ]
door
justin the smaller guy's like what are
we looking at
yes so we all go this way now kyle's
supposed to be filming it that's why i'm
on the road but kyle went i want to live
you know all his camera equipment and
ran out okay
smart so then jay goes we got to go this
way well
it was the only door to the stage i
didn't realize that yeah and it was
locked from the outside or
maybe i just couldn't figure out the
lock right and then everyone's on me
like this like we're wearing the cap oh
i was i was
and i hear chappelle go i'm too young to
die yeah and i went all right we're not
going to die
and then a knife the threat of a knife
or a gun the gun is not scary
but i thought all right we got to get
out of here because this guy's [ __ ]
coming i don't get stabbed
shot so then when you wonder why dead
lift 600 bench for
25 or whatever this is why daddy
shattered that door
shattered did he that was so funny
just ran
was it one time to take one time one
shot one one shot that's
the fear and that kind of size the door
shatters on the side right but here's
the thing
it goes into the crowd yeah it went
straight
here i go oh my god and i go oh
everyone's like yeah i'm like no
no
so then they're like what's the matter i
was like there's a guy with a knife or a
gun
but don't be be cool he's back there
everybody's good and was like what the
[ __ ] let me start walking through the
crowd holy [ __ ]
not here we didn't even realize it went
to the stage i had no idea what it was
you feel like you got to create in that
situation if you run you might be dead
you might want to sit tight stay low
feels good but you let him come in and
then you you just grab the barrel and
you do a krav maga homie was shredded
the homeless man was shredded
he was shredded and he's on meth and
that's a hard that's a lot
that's tough because someone outside
because we just had pulled up
some one of the audience members was
messing with him because he was like
he was being like whenever kind of just
out there you kind of just like
ignore him and then kind of walk away
well
this dude thought he could just like
talk to him be like yo man stop tripping
it's like yo this dude's out of his mind
completely and then what what set the
dude off
is the the homeless man had a beer yeah
and the dude
took his beer yeah and that's what set
him off yeah
and then oh that's why freaking [ __ ]
out yeah so he's like man get my [ __ ]
beer back get my beer back
and then finally dude like puts it down
and you know like tries to like walk
away and
nora but the dude was he was just you
seen big j that's when
he was like get out of here no he didn't
say brendon he said he said my lord
he was like pushing him but he
first of all david lucas 350 pounds
we have about 250. we got to do we got
we got the ones
like we should have that's called the
[ __ ] that's called the one ton club
and the one ton club has to form a
vector and be ready to absorb
come what may you know what set it off
was jay
jay jay was the one that likes
everything well that'll scare me
you know and jay's very serious he's
like run and he's also he doesn't get
excited so when he no
yeah he doesn't when i got scared i'm
like oh [ __ ] and i go where he goes who
gives a [ __ ]
get out he's like it's either gunner
that's
like what i don't want to die either